aujourd'hui mercredi 6 juillet à
l'académie équestre national du domaine
de versailles a eu lieu l'avant première
le repère des contraires c'est un
documentaire de l'oea rinaldi sur la
compagnie donc des contraires qui est
implantée à chanteloup les vignes est
porté par année aux atomes à 6 bonjour à
toutes les deux mais bon je voudrais
avec nous alors je me tourne déjà vers
vous allez à pourquoi ce documentaire si
j'ai bien compris c'est nous à qui est
venu me voir oui c'est inexact nous
revoir dans
ma société de production et elle est
arrivée faut dire parce qu'elle arrive
et que comme le père un personnage avec
des bottes colorées des plumes aux
oreilles et avec une détermination
incroyable en me disant que elle voulait
documenter ce qui allait se passer au
sein de chanteloup les vignes et
notamment la construction du nouveau
chapiteau et au départ j'ai trouvé ça
quand même gonflé mais j'adore les gens
qui sont culotté et évidemment je suis
allé voir je suis resté quelques temps
en immersion et effectivement quand on a
la chance de voir ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur du chapiteau et la magie qui
s'opère on a envie de témoigner et
justement là vous parlez de magie
l'aider ce témoignage c'était de parler
donc de la construction du chapiteau
mais aussi de l'équipe de la renaissance
de l'équipe alors renaissance man parce
que à la base c'était une construction
en dur il y avait juste la
transformation du chapiteau des moussa
en chapiteau
qui appartenait enfin en dur qui allait
appartenir à la mairie des dons et vous
savez la résidence permanente mais non
moi ce qui m'intéressait c'était le
travail donné où ça son travail de mise
en scène d'urgence ont rapport avec les
enfants l'évolution des enfants et tout
le bien que ça leur apporte finalement
là où il n'y a pas grand chose et quand
on donne accès à des enfants à la
culture au théâtre à des activités comme
le cirque qui est très mal connue
voilà c'était ça qui m'intéressait
c'était plutôt le travail à l'intérieur
après l'événement la construction du
tapis tôt c'était super pour suivre
l'évolution et c'est une espèce de
métaphores la construction l'évolution
des enfants la construction du chapiteau
mais oui c'était plutôt l'art en action
que j'avais envie de suivre et justement
les usa ce documentaire ça valorise
votre travail finalement le ce
documentaire pour moi le plus important
c'était des registres et où le parti de
l'histoire de la compagnie de contraire
pour devenir un étude sociologique
d'une communauté chanteloup les vignes
c'était ça vraiment l'objectif quand je
suis allé chercher cette merveilleuse
signer installé rinaldi pour aussi
garder en mémoire une partie de
l'histoire de la compagnie de ma vie
aussi évidemment et comment la culture
peut arriver dans un quartier et des
venir quelque chose d'essentiel mais en
même temps on nettoie et ses ciels être
la cible d tous les attaques possibles
justement je voulais vous demander à
l'oea c'est un tournage qui était long
puisqu'il a duré quatre ans je crois
vous avez débuté en 2010 est pourquoi
autant de temps pour un tournage
finalement alors ben généralement je
prends beaucoup de temps notamment le
documentaire d'immersion parce qu'il
faut un temps d'adaptation faut
connaître les enfants faut savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on veut raconter comment
vous le raconter pour ça je suis pas une
journaliste d'investigation j'ai pas des
questions précises j'ai pas un message à
faire passer pour moi est important de
prendre le temps de réfléchir d'observer
et de laisser vivre les choses voilà moi
je tourne en cinéma direct et c'est ce
qui me semblait le plus juste dans cet
environnement que je connais c'est pas
voilà donc je n'avais pas imposer un
regard j'avais pas imposer ma vision
j'ai laissé l'histoire s'écrire voilà et
c'est que c'est vraiment magnifique dans
l'eau travail délai assez que
elle arrive pour tourner de la journée
et on la voit plus c'est comme si
vraiment c'est vraiment elle disparaît
en milieu avec sa caméra latraverse très
silencieuse et à la capte tout il nous
on oublie qu'elle est là ça présente
c'est pas du tout imposante et ça
c'était merveilleux pour toute la
population qui a peur de la caméra qui a
peur des images etc ça s'est passé
vraiment extrêmement bien on part de
dire un petit mot sur la compagnie
contraire juste pour préciser votre
objectif avec la compagnie c'était de si
j'ai bien compris encore une fois amené
des gens d'horizons différents dans leur
amener la culture et on l'entend dans le
documentaire vous plantez finalement des
petites graines dans dans la tête des
gens et ça leur donne beaucoup d'idées
et vous êtes un peu comme la deuxième
maman en fait de ses enfants avec qui
vous travaillez
est-ce que vous en rendez compte de ça
que vous êtes une force pour eux superbe
et sur totalement je suis leur douzième
moment où je suis c'est qu'ils appellent
la maman du chapiteau et on a un lien
très fort très affective parce que c'est
vrai que je suis un être humain et
rigide dans le travail je me suis
inquiet terrible parce qu' on est dans
un quartier qui a difficilement - et
qu'il faut donner des repères il faut
donner des limites constant enfin mais
derrière tout ça il ya énormément
d'amour dé bienveillance et ils le
savent et je du jeu pendant fin j'ai une
fille luan 1 mais je plainds enfin vous
avez tout fait dans con je vais parler
quand même vous en doutez de l'incident
qui s'est produit du coup pendant le
tournage la 110 en fait du chapiteau je
voulais savoir comment vous vous l'a dit
vécu parce que c'était vraiment prendre
en tournage vous vous étiez là derrière
votre caméra vous étiez là parce qu'il y
avait la compagnie comment vous l'avez
vécu
moi j'étais au brésil avec un groupe de
déchanter mauvaise en train de faire un
projet on a su là bas avant de prendre
l'avion on a vu les images de l'incendié
mais j'ai vécu ça comme quelque chose de
très dur évidemment c'est un grand
traumatisme que nous avons vécu tous un
traumatisme qui n'était pas du tout
soutenu ni assisté on n'a pas ou
distancer des cellules et des crises
rien on était vraiment largués alors moi
il fallait que je travaille avec les
enfants traumatisés avec les familles
traumatisées avec mon équipe traumatisée
et le soir quand j'avais le temps il
fallait que je travaille sur moi même
qui était traumatisée alors nous avons
vécu vraiment un gros traumatisme et en
même temps un grand abandon et ça c'est
important de dire parce que les gens les
servants pas content moi je n'ai appris
j'étais en terrasse dans le café j'ai
reçu un roi de s'abonner ou 100 watts à
pau audio quand même on en voit beaucoup
et là j'ai entendu d'ailleurs j'ai
utilisé son message clairement envoyé et
me dit léa le chapiteau en train de
brûler voilà en fait son émotion on
dirait qu'elle m'a témoignée j'allais me
gênait mise dans le film si on reste ici
dans cet espace non
dès lors
c'est la bêtise qui ont à cet agrément
mais non on n'accepte pas la violence en
tout cas ce film on pourra le voir en
octobre 2022 en octobre 2022 il sort au
cinéma et on espère que vous serez
nombreux à venir le voir voilà super
évincé noté merci à toutes les 2 1 les
merlus nadir et neuza tomassi merci à
tous les deux d'avoir été un récit
[Musique]